من جانبه قال عمار حجازي مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الفلسطيني ان نقاشات محكمه العدل
الدوليه وضعت العالم مره اخرى امام حقيقه
الجرائم الاسرائيليه في حق الشعب
الفلسطيني ومنها الاباده الجماعيه الحاليه
فضلا عن كل الانتهاكات منذ 75
عاما لقد وضعت النقاشات
اليوم المحكمه والتي تقدمت بها جنوب
افريقيا المحكمه والعالم بصوره الجرائم
التي ترتكب بحق الشعب الفلسطيني والتي
تفضي الى ارتكاب جريمه الاباده الجماعيه
ولكن ايضا في السياق التاريخ الاشمل
للقضيه الفلسطينيه والجرائم التي ترتكب
بحق الشعب الفلسطيني بدءا من النكبه
والاستعمار ونهب ارضه والتمييز العنصري
وكل ما الى ذلك من انتهاكات كانت ترتكبها
اسرائيل على مدار 75 عام هذه لحظه تاريخيه
للشعب الفلسطيني
للانسانيه وكذلك للنظام الدولي المبني على
والقائم على القانون